[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Hi, everyone.
[INAUDIBLE] at the
Life of Your Code demo.
And I'm joined here by Girija.
How are you?
GIRIJA SATHYAMURTHY: Good.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
Tell us a little bit about what
you do and what you've made.
GIRIJA SATHYAMURTHY: Awesome.
So I lead Product Marketing
here in Google Cloud
for our serverless products.
And we recently announced a
product called Cloud Run today.
And I'm really
excited about that.
SPEAKER: Right.
Can you show us what it does?
GIRIJA SATHYAMURTHY: Super.
So I'm just going to
build a simple app.
And we're going to
get started here.
So what we're doing
right now is think
of the train as the app itself.
So we are going to
start by customizing it
first and building our
train, so building the app.
So adding different components
like Compute, Database,
and so on to the train,
building the train,
so it's checking for security
vulnerabilities and all
of those in the second step.
And then finally, we're
going to deploy it.
And we'll be able to see
it on the big screen.
SPEAKER: Awesome.
Let's get started.
GIRIJA SATHYAMURTHY: Super.
So getting started here,
adding a train car first.
So the first thing
that we're going to add
is the engine itself.
So engine here is
the Compute platform.
So let's start with the Compute.
So Cloud Run is amazing because
it enables the developer
to write apps in any
language they choose.
So for example, with
Node.js or C Sharp, Python,
are the options we have here.
But really, any
language they can
choose to write their apps
on, and it's totally fine.
So I'm just going to
select a blue color here
and then getting started.
So now that's our engine.
So we're going to add a
second train car here.
So what we really did was
just selecting a language.
And each language has a
Docker file that goes with it.
So as a developer,
what they're doing
is they're writing code in
any language they choose.
And then the Docker file
is what they specify.
As a developer, if I'm a
Java developer, for example,
and the cloud vendor
doesn't support Java,
that's totally fine.
I can specify the
Docker file, and it's
going to package my
app into a container,
and it's going to deploy it.
So that's what
we're seeing here.
So I'm going to select Go.
Let's do this colorful.
Yeah.
SPEAKER: Yeah, that looks cool.
Little polka dots.
GIRIJA SATHYAMURTHY:
And so finally,
now what we're going to do
is add a database to it.
So this is a database
that I'm going to add.
Because databases are
an essential component
of building an app.
So there are different
options that you
can add if you want
integrated with Cloud Run.
So we have a few options
here, like MongoDB, or Redis,
or Postgres.
Really, it works with any of our
Google Cloud offerings as well.
So you can-- a lot of
options to choose from.
So let's select one of
these a green color.
Let's go ahead.
SPEAKER: Right, so we've
completed the build.
GIRIJA SATHYAMURTHY: Yeah.
So now what we have
here is this is the app.
So think of it as
a developer writing
code for the entire app.
And they're ready to go.
As a developer, this is
all you will have to do,
which is core to
what they're doing.
They don't have to worry about
the infrastructure, scaling it
up and down, monitoring
it, managing it.
All of that has gone away.
SPEAKER: Just focus on the code.
GIRIJA SATHYAMURTHY:
Just the code.
Just focus on the code.
And now we're going
to complete the build.
So for this particular
showcase, it's
using Cloud Build underneath
it to build a container image.
So that's what is
happening right now.
It's pushing the
code to Cloud Run.
So it's checking for
security vulnerabilities.
It's making sure the build
image, the container image,
is being created.
So now you can see the
scanning, the security scanning,
for the code as well,
using Cloud Build.
And now, all of
this is complete.
We're going to give it a name.
SPEAKER: With your initials--
GS.
GIRIJA SATHYAMURTHY: GS.
SPEAKER: Right.
Ta-da.
GIRIJA SATHYAMURTHY:
Yeah, so now
we are going to just apply it.
This is the exciting part.
So the train is actually going
to be seen on the large screen
in just about a second now.
SPEAKER: Awesome.
Oh, there it goes.
GIRIJA SATHYAMURTHY: That's
the app, the fun train.
So now what it's doing is
it's going through the train
station of the QPS there.
Then it's getting
a ton of traffic.
So think of your app as a
lot of users using your app.
So it's getting
a lot of traffic.
And Cloud Run will automatically
scale your app from zero,
literally, if there's no
traffic, to whatever instance
it needs, and then bring it
back down to zero, all just
within seconds.
SPEAKER: Wow, that was a
really great demonstration.
Thank you so much
for joining us.
GIRIJA SATHYAMURTHY:
Thank you for having me.
[MUSIC PLAYING]